From a live-action Disney adaptation to some
of the biggest sci-fi films of the year, March
is stacked with movies well worth checking
out at the box office.
Update your calendar, fill your pockets with
snacks, shovel your car out of the snow, and
check out this onslaught of March movies.
Logan
Director James Mangold's Logan really could
be Hugh Jackman's last hurrah as Wolverine.
The film is a loose adaptation of Marvel's
Old Man Logan comics arc, and will dive into
the darker side of the X-Men universe's possible
future.
The film also features fan-favorite Wolverine
clone X-23's big-screen debut.
The story finds an aged Wolverine, with a
failing healing factor and broken spirit,
protecting an older Professor X at the end
of his life.
The early trailers look fantastic, and Jackman
even took a pay cut to ensure the filmmakers
would have the flexibility to create the R-rated
story properly.
Get ready for the end on March 3rd.
Before I Fall
Think of it like Groundhog Day, but a lot
bleaker, and for the teen girl set.
This sci-fi-lite drama is based on the 2010
novel of the same name by Lauren Oliver, and
follows a 17-year-old girl who has to relive
the day of her death over and over until she
figures out how to get it "right."
Young Sam, played by Zoey Deutch, uses her
time loop to try and avoid her fate, and eventually
finds the freedom to take chances — and
learns there's a lot more to life than she thought.
Check it out on March 3rd.
And then check it out again.
And again.
T2: Trainspotting 2
It's been more than 20 years, but director
Danny Boyle is back with the long-awaited
sequel to his cult-hit-black-comedy-crime-drama,
complete with original stars Ewan McGregor,
Ewen Bremner, Jonny Lee Miller, and Robert
Carlyle.
Expectations are high for Boyle to follow
up his modern classic, but by loosely basing
the story on the original novel's sequel,
Porno, he at least has a template to follow.
Reviews have been largely positive in the
UK, where T2 is already in theaters.
Spot it in the US on March 3rd.
Kong: Skull Island
Hollywood's most famous angry ape, aside from
Gary Busey, returns to the big screen on March
10th, alongside A-listers Tom Hiddleston,
Samuel L. Jackson, John Goodman, John C. Reilly,
and Brie Larson.
The plot seems fairly predictable, but still
relentlessly fun: a team of explorers and
soldiers venture onto an uncharted island
in the Pacific, which just happens to include
a whole lot of monsters.
"I call them skullcrawlers."
"Why?"
"I never said that name out loud before.
Sounds stupid now that I say it, just --- you
call them whatever you want."
Legendary is reportedly looking to combine
the worlds of Kong and Godzilla for the first
time since their first showdown in 1962, so
this one should also help set the stage for
even more monster insanity.
You just know they're gonna bring the big
guy back to New York, right?
The Belko Experiment
This high-concept horror film was written
by Guardians of the Galaxy's James Gunn and
follows a group of 80 white-collar office
workers trapped in a violent social experiment
in which the work day suddenly becomes a life-or-death
game.
It's basically Glengarry Glen Ross meets Battle
Royale meets Saw, and features a long list
of familiar faces getting spattered with the
blood of their co-workers.
So if you ever wanted to actually see John
McGinley from Office Space going HAM in an office...
get your TPS reports in by March
17th.
Beauty and the Beast
If you're a living, breathing human being,
you already know the story of Beauty and the
Beast, so you're probably not in for any huge
surprises.
Disney has realized that turning its animated
classics into live-action blockbusters is
pretty big business, and this marks the latest
installment of more than 20 planned adaptations.
Like usual, the Mouse House has assembled
an all-star cast, including Emma Watson, Dan
Stevens, Luke Evans, and a whole lot of computers
to make that talking clock believable.
Your furry fantasies come to life on March
17th.
Free Fire
This action comedy from High-Rise director
Ben Wheatley stars Brie Larson, Sharlto Copley,
Armie Hammer, Cillian Murphy and Jack Reynor
as a bunch of criminals who get stuck in an
arms deal gone terribly wrong.
A disagreement turns into a shootout, violent
comedy ensues, and if early buzz is to be
believed, it's full of punchy laughs and a
high injury count.
Free Fire is set to launch in the US on March
17th.
King Arthur: Legend of the Sword
Guy Ritchie is taking a break from his Sherlock
Holmes franchise to put a fresh spin on the
classic story of King Arthur.
Due out March 24th, the story follows a young
Arthur who learns about his royal lineage
after pulling Excalibur from its stone.
With great sword comes great responsibility,
and Arthur has to make some tough decisions.
"I'm happy to talk, but there's no way that
I am fighting."
Despite its obvious period setting, the film
looks like a more modern, action-filled take
on the classic story, filled with A-list talent.
Power Rangers
For adults of a certain age, the re-imagining
of the Power Rangers franchise has been a
long time coming.
The '90s kids' series is getting a big-screen
reboot as a PG-13 action franchise, so if
you've ever wanted to see Bryan Cranston as
a giant disembodied head, your dreams come
true on March 24th.
Director Dean Israelite has put together a
nice mix of stars, including Elizabeth Banks,
and a team of young up-and-comers to play
the teenage Rangers.
Israelite's previous film, Project Almanac,
did a good job with its teen protagonists,
so this one has the potential to be a whole
lot of fun.
One thing's for sure: if Bulk and Skull don't
make a cameo, we riot.
Life
This sci-fi horror thriller follows a team
of astronauts who retrieve a Mars space probe
with a sample inside.
Because nothing good ever comes from Mars,
all hell breaks loose and the crew has to
find a way to stop the space monster while
trapped on board the International Space Station.
If it sounds like Alien, well...that's because
it pretty much is, Alien — with a twist.
The cast of doomed spacemen includes Jake
Gyllenhaal, Rebecca Ferguson, Ryan Reynolds,
and Hiroyuki Sanada.
Get probed on March 24th.
CHiPS
This buddy cop comedy stars writer/director
Dax Shepard and Michael Peña as two California
Highway Patrol motorcycle officers who investigate
a corrupt police department by making at least
one weiner joke every three minutes.
Sure, CHiPS is a comedy-centric remake of
the 1970s TV drama, but that worked out pretty
well for 21 Jump Street.
"My name's Jeff."
"That's Jefe, man."
Remember how much you liked the Starsky and
Hutch and Dukes of Hazzard movies?
Well, even if you didn't, there's still a
lot of talent and potential here.
Ride or die on March 24th.
Ghost in the Shell
The long-awaited live-action adaptation of
this acclaimed manga and anime looks like
one of the most ambitious sci-fi films of
the year.
Scarlett Johansson, no stranger to skin-tight
action, stars as the cyborg Major, as she
and her counter-cyberterrorist unit they take
on cyber-saboteurs.
The film looks to be a gorgeous translation
of the visuals from the anime, so no matter
how it turns out, there seems to be no doubt
director Rupert Sanders has built something gorgeous.
Ghost in the Shell gets uploaded to theaters
on March 31st.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!